[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett I
thought I had to sneeze again but I
don't what I'm link the guy who thought
he had to sneeze again but he didn't you
sneeze three times a second try to keep
it even numbers this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we got a
catch-up brother because we both went on
separate family vacations I don't know
if I can call mine a vacation I call it
a sightseeing excursion via RV I'm very
excited about it to hear from you and
for you to hear from me yeah we have we
actually we got in Monday of this week
so coming right back from vacation we
saw each other in the morning getting
ready to shoot good mythical morning at
the desk and we didn't even really ask I
mean I just know it's implied we
shouldn't I just said how was it right
but but you knew that I didn't want you
to tell me any details right it was just
good that's all you said right it's like
nobody I mean nothing tragic happened
that like on a personal level we need to
discuss before we publicly and for
monetization purposes like conduct our
friendship well that's the thing that
you you got to remember about your
biscuits is that I'm not doing this for
the money though I'm doing this for for
the gist of love I didn't have to bring
in the monetization no I mean that's you
don't want people to think about that
nope I mean we talked enough about how
you need to buy the two t-shirts that
we're wearing right now yeah just let
that just sort of wash over people right
but we we hold back these conversations
so then we can have them raw unfiltered
for the first time so I'm gonna be
finding out details about your vacation
that normal friends would have already
covered right but we've waited days I've
been wondering you been you've been
hinting people then cuz everybody the
whole crew yeah knew you were gonna be
an RV and everybody was like how was it
everybody want everybody and you haven't
been divulging anything but everybody's
asking like cuz they know something went
wrong
you know it's like but put link horse in
his family in an RV something's
something's bound to go wrong yeah I
mean so people aren't asking because
they they want it to be good they're
asking because they want it to be
entertaining yeah and you know what
that's why you got an RV just so you can
talk about it well Lando who is 8 now
was invited by a friend of his to go on
an RV trip with their family and I'm
like son don't do it you don't want to
be trapped in a vehicle did your seat
just sink I did stop distracting me with
your seat hi
trying to get to the right place I said
you don't wanna be trapped with another
family son out in a vehicle you want to
be trapped with our family and that fell
through and he was excited so then
always wanted to fulfill his dream of
going an RV trip and I started it
started become my dream but what really
put it over the edge was this right now
like knowing that like it it it's a
beautiful thing to like to take a risk
and okay put your whole family at
recreational risk because even in the
worst case in it well I won't say worst
case no I don't want to say somebody
dies or it gets maimed but like in a bad
case scenario like like the vacation
sucks
it still is redeemed by the fact that I
can talk about it here it's like it's
like a friend of mine said you know what
when we moved out to California and he
knew that we were in the video making
business he said remember it's better to
have a good story than a good time so I
kind of live by that I I still don't
know he's like know about that advice
but well I just like knowing even if
something's goes wrong or sideways well
at least I can talk about what you're
the one who said raw like usually goes
wrong but I kind of like goes wrong yeah
thanks I thought these these underwear
would be comfortable but they're going
wrong oh gosh it's a lot of chafing um
so I rented the RV I did not purchase an
RV that would be stupid
that would be stupid well but a lot of
people do purchased and you don't want
the RV you don't want the RV owners to
quit listening to you and I ran into a
bunch of those people well
I cross paths with a bunch of those
people yeah
and they knew that you were a renter
they're much yeah you got it although
maybe I'll get back to that if if
they're more exciting things of my story
don't pan out you're much too fit to be
an RV owner you know what I'm saying
well I mean even the RV forums say well
you should you should rent an RV and you
should and there was you know I was
starting to wig out like reading all the
stuff leading up to it like well you
should you should go on a short trip
just to get a feel for it you don't want
to go on a long trip before the marathon
yeah you want to just like get a feel
for everything you got to know how to
empty the tanks and there's so many
tanks on an RV I go to pick up the thing
and the guys walking me through it and
every time he would tell me something
like first thing he did was like now you
put your put the garden hose on this and
you fill it up with water got it and
then he and there was a valve a sudden
he was like and then when you get to the
place you put their garden hose up to
this place and you connected
semi-permanently got it hmm and I
noticed a pattern because then the next
thing he like squats down and there's of
there's like two pull handles and a big
pipe and he was like this is where you
get rid of your why did he call it gray
water and your black water and you got
up you got to hook up your hose to run
it into their septic tank before you
pull this valve for the black water
because if you pull the black water
valve first you're gonna have your
family stinky all over you
got it yeah and everything so he would
and these like then you pull the grey
one and it runs the rest of the the you
know what the black out of the out of
the tube flushes this with your with
your sink and you're in your shower
water I got it got it I got it and every
single time he'd be looking down and he
would he'd lock eyes with me and he said
got it
and I just started I looked at Christie
I was like it's like I'm I literally
thought do I have a stupid look on my
face if I shouldn't ask that question
do you want me to answer it yeah I mean
why did he keep saying is it it's a it's
a tic that he had well he is his job is
explaining things to people and if
seeing if they got it what what do you
mean I got I'm listening to you man I'm
I'm a I'm a college graduate but well
I'm an intern that doesn't have anything
to do with it a lot of people don't
listen got it
and also you do tend to have a look on
your face that you tend to go into your
own world usually not when somebody's
talking I mean a lot of times I know
maybe he only does it with you because
there are times you think it's my face
I'm I know I don't think you look stupid
I think you can sometimes have stupid
looks look yeah it's a disengaged look
okay very often I'll on I known you I've
known you for so long that I know I'd
say seven out of ten sentences I start
and then don't continue because I
recognize that you're not ready I
recognize that you ain't going at it if
I start if I keep talking come on my
mind is somewhere else but but usually
once I want you well you're in a beige
and you're in you're sitting there
watching something at that point I don't
keep confirming I just then I'm going
with the flow
I was very engaged I don't think it was
my face because I was nervous about like
pulling the Dookie shoot at the wrong
time yeah you know never want to do that
and there's like we're not even inside
the RV there's gauges in there for water
levels and generators and AC units and
this is how the fridge would fridge
won't work if it's not level it's like
all this stuff you got ins and outs but
I got it and I brought it home I pulled
it into my driveway and I left it there
for a couple of days just to get
acclimated I got a rented it two days
early just so we could they can start
packing stuff in it the kids could put
their shenanigans in there their
knickknacks and whatnot to be
comfortable and there'd be no excuses
for not having everything because you
had days four to start putting stuff in
and you're not having fun no excuse for
not having fun no excuses for that and
then I finally I come home from shooting
and we're
immediately gonna get in the RV and go
it's go time and it is pouring down rain
yeah it was raining oh hey it doesn't
rain in here there's a whole song about
it
Tony Tony Tony yeah it never rains in
Southern California yeah
great album well Tony Tony Tony is out
of touch touch touch cuz it was raining
and raining and raining like cats and
dogs you remember you were leaving for
your vacation at the same time I guess
just in a normal car though
genius so so I'm I hadn't filled up our
tank with water so I'm filling it up
with water weighing this thing down get
all my family in there feeling up to
what the water tank for like this spigot
and everything and yeah for flushing the
toilet for like hooking a hose up to it
yeah and then you unhook the hose before
you drag off but when you get to a site
you can use their water instead of using
the water from your tank got it so I'm
like Christie I need you to stand out in
the rain I'm sorry and make sure I don't
back into like my neighbor's car
something I got to back out of this
driveway and I'm gonna back up the
street into the cul-de-sac and I I want
you to say if I can't see you in a
mirror if you can't see me in a mirror I
cannot see you and I do not want to run
over you at this juncture right but I
need you to be out there bad way to
start kill your wife right at the
beginning so so I'm like I'm she gets
out there I put it in reverse
everybody's in the dogs in and I'm like
all right Christie I'm backing up so I
start backing up and then all of a
sudden the RV hits something oh gosh and
it stops cold what in the world did you
hit at the end of my driveway it it's at
a slope and then the street kind of goes
up the other way so comments it kind of
crowns so there's a there's a ditch by
the way with flowing torrential waters
the rain going through it that like a
ditch well the whole back end of the RV
just like
into the asphalt of my street just like
you bought about a bottom because when I
pulled in I was light and I you know
what come to think of it when I pulled
in there was a little scrape he's great
yes you get immediately get all the kids
to take all the stuff they wanted to
throw it out into the yard
start with the heavy stuff the largest
kid all the people beside you out I
wasn't gonna do that because it's
pouring down rain and I was like Oh
start panicking a little bit like I know
I gotta hold this inside I can't let my
family see that I'm crapping a brick and
now I'm falling apart here my wife's out
in the rain
she's like you hit the street you you
hit the street that's died that's how
you want your vacation to start you hit
the street and what does that even mean
and I'm like oh gosh and I'm like yeah
solution solution solution focus on
positives to lose that engineering
degree so I remembered around my house I
just start running over there and you
know I you know how when I started to
get panicky and I'm trying to come up
with solution I don't know I'm I'm in
communicative so I run out you should
you start using real words yeah I
started I'll say like the first half of
a sentence like my family hates this I'm
like and Christie's tailing me around
the house and I'm like I got an idea I
can I can and then I start picking up
the extra pavers that the construction
company used to like make my driveway
like little in language like pavers let
so it's not like a concrete driveway and
so I grabbed those heavy and then I just
started I'm like hold the gate open and
I'm like it's pouring down rain I'm like
I made probably ten trips getting these
heavy pavers filling in the ditch like
to make up I pulled the RV back up and
then I started making a path for the
back wheels to elevate it yeah like two
concrete bridges and then I I mean
thirty minutes later I'm like drenched
I'm sweating I'm panicking like kids are
coming out they're like are we still
going on this trip I'm like get back in
the RV don't get it's a danger zone out
here you might get hit I don't know
what's happening I sent it across the
land bridge yeah and then I get them all
back in and I except for Christi and
said she had a raincoat she's a raincoat
and I'm like all right I'm going for it
and I get in the car and I smash on the
brake in order to pull the emergency
brake and then I cry I'm like I'm
cranking out the car and I'm gonna back
up slowly over the bridge that I've made
I crank it up nothing just dead as a
doornail oh gosh I'm like I'm like I'm a
failure it was just I was just like I I
was this close to just slamming my head
against the stairwell just like her just
like gather round neighbors look at your
fit look at the fail your father yeah I
can't let him he cannot lose confidence
and dad he's been planning an RV trip
for months out of the driveway here
Christie's here in the the failing crank
it like what turn over and I couldn't
make eye contact with her I just
you shouldn't at that point and then I
was like then I looked down and I did
not have my foot on the brake
I was flooring the gas pedal of my RV
what I my had it pedal to the metal I
was like because I I wasn't familiar
with the gas in the gas is it on a
different side in an RV what no it's
just it's all a little further to the
left so what I thought you were flooding
it I put yeah I was flooding I thought I
was putting my foot smash right in the
middle of the rain I'm glad it didn't
crank up I know I flooded the engine
about what could have happened
and so I took my foot off of the gas and
I put it on the brake and I was like
just like just a pray or crank and I
cranked it and three times and it did in
cranked third time charm and then I'm
like now I got to get over this this
cinderblock bridge that I've made right
so I go over that and it's like it took
a little off for like I didn't I
couldn't ease because I built quite a
yeah you gotta get up on the bridge
I had to be kind of aggressive and I
went up on it and then BAM like it
cracks the whole bridge gonna say it had
to crack a bridge it cracked the bridge
and but I kept going and then we were we
we were off you're on the road well I
had to I had now you're gonna get rid of
the land minute security land bridge
right and then Chrissy's like go in the
house you're soaked just go in the house
change
take a breather you know what we can get
if you can get a fresh start get a fresh
set of clothes you know fresh underwear
now that you've gotten out of the
driveway it's time for a clothes change
first our driveway yeah that's good gosh
okay what an idiot
so I'm assuming the trip continued and
you got it you will tell me more about
that that's all I'd care to share and
I'm it's better and more interesting
after that and I'll tell you a little
bit about my trip as well but first we
want to let you know as we hinted at
earlier that both shirts that we are
wearing I'm wearing the constellation
good mythical morning tea and Link is
wearing the mythical beast II this is
not the I am a mythical beast tea this
is an artist collaboration we've got
nine individually designed mythical
beasts who are eating certain certain
snacks that when you look closely you
see there's a story to tell
yeah and they're all traditional well
for the most part it's a combination of
traditionally recognized mythical beasts
and then mythical beasts from the rhett
and Link universe like the ranlo and the
cockatrice and the will efficient whole
from our book but also it yet eat no ice
cream cone yeah
so mythical dot store yeah guess so
check out our amazon store go to amazon
and it was not calm slash mythical yeah
is that what that is
yes
your shirt is one of my favorites the
constellation good mythical morning
shirt kind of hard to see on camera here
but you feel like a star and in real
life it's easy to see how fashionable
you will be thanks for supporting
entertainment you know what I need all
the help I can get if I haven't
established that sorry I saw I got on
the road I got I got some more stuff to
talk about the RV but I don't want to
hog every I do want to hear about your
trip
well RV lists yeah wall trip to Palm
Springs first thing we were right out of
the driveway just like a just like a
bullet I mean no problem at all I didn't
change clothes or anything I didn't have
to build a land bridge I just I backed
out and then got on the road kind of
like every time you back out of you yeah
yeah yeah I mean you know you know my
driveway my driveway is not easy to get
out of you let me tell you brother and
don't put an RV up that your driveway
there's a lot that can go wrong with my
driveway but you know thankfully we got
right on the road we went to Palm
Springs you already know this if you
follow me on Instagram shout out to red
MC on Instagram that make it doesn't
even make sense to shout it that's not
good
you're like such a such a dad thing that
I want people to know shout-out to
mayest like it's not little I just want
people to know if they want to know
about these things first before they as
they're happening read em see on
Instagram Christy Christy did tell me
afterward she was like I thought about
pulling up my phone and taking pictures
of that bridge or oh she look on your
face yeah that would have been into that
video I was actually my family I didn't
do it my family was keeping up with your
trip a little bit through the various
Instagram stories from your kids and
your wife oh yeah yeah so that's how I
knew and I think I knew a little bit
about what was texting Jesse because I
was like what you doing over there
you're not telling you're not telling
buddy about what happened I she just
said that there was some trouble getting
out of the driveway that's all that's
all I knew I did not know what that
meant I'm glad I got the full story
though you know I had a great vacation
it was a vacation it wasn't too
adventurous we like stated a
you know like a Resort and Spa situation
you know mostly the the lounging beside
the pool when you go to Palm Springs is
it like you're entering 1960 again
that's how I picture in a lot of ways
yeah it's uh you know it's like the
birthplace of mid-century modern
architecture so you go through these
neighborhoods and you could easily think
if you didn't see the modern cars that
you were it was 1962 this one story
houses super mid-century modern and they
all kind of look similar but then
they've got like the different colored
doors or whatever did you Airbnb in one
you could probably do that we didn't we
stayed at hotel but and there's and
there's like though there's a whole like
movement that pays homage to those the
times gone by so lots of neon signs and
like there's like a bunch of old men who
drive big old cars it's kind of a place
for old dudes who'd like to play golf
like some great golf courses out there
and there's a lot of old people oh yeah
RV parks as it turns out because I've I
stayed in three I actually passed a
number of our parks you know they were
um you think about old people you think
about it permanent residents of RV parks
when you know that you you there's
somebody out there that you know isn't
an RV you start seeing RVs yeah yeah
yeah saw a lot RVs there's called our
vision yes that's what you get when your
friends in an RV and you're feeling I
had it all week but national vision as I
told you on the last podcast when we
were getting ready to to leave as much
as you wanted to you know ride atop a
mule down into the bottom of the Grand
Canyon I and you didn't you weren't able
to do that I did get to ride at least a
horse again you already know this if
you're following me on Instagram I won't
shout it out again chris Christie first
time Christie handed me your phone and
showed me your Instagram picture I kind
of took it for you even reloading I
rubbed it in a little bit but also I was
on a white horse with the with the
cowboy hat yeah and apparently I think I
had the cowboy hat on backwards
is that what the comments a few comments
pointed that out and I'm not 100% sure I
went back and looked at all the photos
and I was like I don't know if it's on
backwards or not I got the guy probably
did on purpose did the cat come with the
tour
uh he's no okay so we can go by hat did
yeah I did not buy a hat no in the place
where we we were getting ready to go
there was the option of wearing a helmet
and of course the kids have to wear a
helmet and then the adults have the
option to wear a helmet my life macht
were a helmet on a horse
they almost everyone does okay that's
smart and I think that it is the right
choice but I was like I'm not gonna wear
a helmet I'm gonna wear that cowboy hat
that they had up there I was like he's
that cowboy hat also available to wear
anything he was like yeah so I was like
I'm gonna wear that and you know it did
my wife was a similar protection no the
brim stiff I think that we would offered
some protection but I was like how much
trouble can you get on a horse and then
my wife is like what you got mad at me
she's like what about what happened to
Christopher Reeve and I'm like well hey
he was jumping over things and B he had
a frickin helmet on he broke his neck is
this isn't I this it's not what I'm
trying to protect myself hon did you do
research in the midst of your argument
to find out that he was wearing a helmet
how would you know that well I'm
assuming he had a helmet on because he
was in competition oh oh I get it
it's like a jump okay and they aware
helmets the horses are jumping my horse
is going to go on a single-wide trail at
3 miles per hour hey I do I don't think
I need a helmet that was my decision
caused a little contention but anyway I
put the cowboy hat on backwards got on
the white horse like a boss I mean now
first of all so we follow the trailer
full full of our horses and so we we
don't we they just kind of looked at us
and they like selected four horses we
never saw the horses we drive to the
place where we have access to the trail
and then the horses start getting out
and they start matching us with horses
and so they like say they bring this
little horse out and they're like that's
for you Shepherd and then they another
horse that's for you second oldest boy
second boy
um and then this ma'am this this this
horse is for you and then there and then
there's like okay what's the horse
what's the last horse and they had three
Brown horses and then out of the trailer
comes this giant white horse and Jesse
says oh no don't put him on a white
horse as if his ego all needs that and
so I get on the white horse name Spanky
thank you really kind of takes the wind
out of it and this the the most notable
thing about this trip was our guide yeah
who had in a very interesting connection
to you and what you were experiencing my
uncle at the Grand Canyon what well I'll
tell you that in a second but quickly
you give me a teaser that's not how we
do cuz it because that comes a little
bit later okay this guy Tony was his
name former bull rider Tony if Tony Tony
Tony no that would be too perfect okay
and this my bull rider so he I knew
right off the bat this last guy was a
character just a character had this like
midwest cowboy kind of accent that's not
quite southern but you know it's just
interesting Grubb and Maddie not paddy
wagon what's it called chuck wagon I
took his hand yeah and it was like it
was like he had just put his hand into
like a you know like a grinder
belt sander every day for three hours I
mean it was just amazing his the way his
hand felt and like every knuckle was as
big as a cue ball you know I'm saying it
was just and then he starts talking a
little bit and I'm like you know how'd
you get into this and he was like well I
was a bull rider first he's older guy
and I was like oh really
you professional bull rider say how many
bones did you break he's like 47 he was
like so ready he was so ready with that
you know yeah yeah he had been talking
about like the geology of the place and
it was in the history and it was really
interesting but then once we got him on
talking about himself
it was when the entertainment began oh
yeah again you were going three miles
per hour on horses that incidentally
stop and want to eat everything really
and he was like yeah it's like a salad
bar for him out here and they're eating
everything classic yeah in the desert
just going through the desert and indian
canyons is what they call this elevation
changer a little bit but not not a lot
it didn't like get cold or anything but
it is beautiful and you like go into the
canyons where the palm trees have been
growing for years since the spanish came
and planted them you know when the 1600s
or whatever that's how palm trees got
the california learned that they're not
native learned that from a bull rider
but anyway this dude i mean i don't want
to get I don't want to divulge Allah he
wasn't even necessarily super
comfortable talking about all the stuff
that he ended up telling us like this
dude almost crying
no he just doesn't like to talk about
himself but we kept asking so many
questions a cowboy Rhett they they're
known for not doing I know but we asked
questions and he kept answering and he
had these amazing stories this dude
reluctance Norton he had a story about
falling off of a cliff and the horse
fell on him he broke every rib every
single rib and then he had to be he laid
there for an hour he was in he was in
Yellowstone Yallah snow waiting for the
bear guides who were out there
patrolling to come get him and put him
on a horse and take him back he had
another experience where he was
clinically dead for a number of minutes
and saw some very interesting things he
has recurrent dreams where he has these
did these dreams that'll happen and
they'll happen like he's like I dreamed
this 18 nights in a row
Oh heaven he tells this tell us what it
is just just an amazing look I mean like
wicked stuff
no just interesting stuff where the very
specific things happen and he's being
followed by multiple people on horseback
and he turns around and he can't make
out their faces and then they all start
flying and he's like then I wake up and
then it happened every night for
eighteen days
and then we're like well what's your
interpretation he's like I'm still
figuring that out and he you know he
reminded me of afford his guts out he
reminded me of me not you
Jack Palance his character from city
slickers Curley was that his name well I
haven't seen the movie but I do thought
scarlet gosh you gotta watch that movie
in fact as we were out there Jesse said
the same thing she was like we got to
watch city slickers with the kids
because this guy is him he won like Best
Supporting Actor yeah but anyway he just
it was a treat it was an absolute treat
to have this guy tell us this stuff did
you yet did you try to ask him maybe the
kid the horses go faster I thought about
that at a time but what I did is he said
if you want the horses to go faster like
if your horse falls behind cuz he was
leaning then just give it a livin a nice
little kick
not it's like it's not even really it
doesn't hurt oh it's a signal you just
kind of put your heels into their side
belly there and so I got my horse was
taking a break to eat which he did a lot
so think he was hungry and jesse was in
front of me she got a little bit away
and then I kind of did the little kick
and Spanky got moving and when your
horse gets moving you get moving and
like like yes it was uncomfortable in
the in the nether regions
okay like I feel like I missed something
like he didn't I didn't get a tutorial
on how to like protect the boys once the
course starts Khaled meal boy swell up
the size of Curly's knuckles I think so
and so I I was like I know that there's
got to be a technique for this because
I'm every cowboy doesn't have bruise
Paul's I mean there's they figure it out
somehow how you remove them yeah keep
him in touch all Cowboys castrated
before now they put them back in Oh
after like marbles it's like a sack of
marbles right well mouths I don't have a
sack of marbles situation so I was in a
little bit of pain of course it doesn't
matter cuz they don't work anymore
saddlebag it's what saddlebags are for
now I will say this here's the
connection yeah here's the connection so
bring this back to me it first of all if
you are gonna go do this do this trip
I'm a little jealous but I would want to
go fast he also
it was like family friends with Garth
Brooks his family well he's a cowboy
which because they their farms his dad's
farm and then like the Garth in Oklahoma
no it's like Wyoming is where they grew
up but it up and up against each other
so he's got like Garth Brooks growing up
stories to Weaver like you should write
a book he's like I don't I don't want to
do that anyway so if you take Tony
get Tony's tour this is like a
Travelocity moment yeah but the thing is
is like he may not want you to eat you
know he may not want to tell everybody
these stories so don't ask Tony good to
see if he wants to talk about it now he
said I said my my best friend and
business partner he's currently in the
Grand Canyon conversation went to me I
preview ever and he and he wanted to
take the mules down into the Grand
Canyon yeah I said you ever done that he
says 27,000 miles worth yeah wait 27,000
miles he's dead 27,000 miles of
experience more than up and down once
I'll tell you and he decides he's been
all over the place he says my good
friend over three Empire State
building's worth of height in that Grand
Canyon his friend is the guy who is
currently in charge of the program holds
a world record for the number of miles
into the Grand Canyon on the mule it's
like 42,000 he's logging a lot of miles
and he said there's an 18-month waiting
list yeah and then you tell me about the
lodge down at the bottom then you you go
down on a mule and then there's a lodge
down there and you spend the night yeah
it sounds like main tamping snare and
then because you can't do it all in one
day and then you ride the mule back up
and I heard that of all the people that
die every year in the Grand Canyon it's
never because of a mule ride never there
they're fewer footed they're so reliable
right I did see the mules you saw him in
a corral but I did not go to the top of
a Bright Angel Falls Trail or whatever
it's called
the one that they they that they take
everyone down he told me I really want
to go back my family won't do it I'd
love for the two of us to go back I'll
totally do it and we have the hook-up
now oh yeah and yeah he said call me
skip the waiting list you know we might
be able to work something out
but he gave me a boss on one mule yeah I
might get a discount mule but he did say
last thing I want to get back to your
your trip he said that the astronauts
after they went on the moon if you
believe that kind of thing when they got
back from the moon trip they stayed at
that Lodge at the bottom of the Grand
Canyon for a month why to be completely
out of the the limelight to be basically
in a place where the press could not get
to them and they could decompress and he
was like a lot of people know that but I
know it because I've know the guys who
run that camp Wow it's a everybody
that's that's what they say in that
astronaut Stadium when you need to
decompress like an astronaut at the
bottom of the canyon so anyway that was
my highlight I have another funny story
that I will get to but I want to back to
you link of course I'd seen the Grand
Canyon because on our mythical road trip
where we drove a u-haul pulling my
minivan all the way across the country
and we had these videos are on the
rhettandlink channel and actually the
good mythical morning channel to where
we like had fan meetups at rest areas as
we drove interstate 40 all the way
across the country
what was that seven years ago now 2011
yeah but we took a detour off 40 to the
green hey we didn't plan it we were like
let's see the Grand Canyon we did for
maybe an hour so I'd seen it so when I
when we finally get there in the RV and
you know it the kids have space it's
nice I'm going 65 miles an hour with a
speed limit of 70 because you really
can't push this thing that hard but
there's a bed above the cab and even
though you it's probably not that safe
kinda like you're not wearing a helmet
you want to also there's a different
speed limit for those vehicles no you're
talking if if you're pulling a trailer
have three axles you have to drive 55 oh
but not the RV so they each had space to
be on the screen or Jade was nervous she
sat with Christian in the passenger seat
so they don't say buckle it up inside
her know the sign in the RV says stay
buckled up but but what's the lien in
rvv
yeah I knew that was never gonna happen
I just had to be careful so we had a
really good experience in the RV driving
up there you wherever you stop
you've got everything at your disposal
it's with you including anything you
need to dispose of a toilet or a trash
can like you don't have to get out for
anything except to stretch your legs I
really like that when we got so the
first night we stayed in Kingman just a
town off route 66 got there after dark
after leaving so late I was delayed did
I mention that get up the next morning
and we so we had driven like five hours
you drove the we drove the other almost
three hours to the Grand Canyon we drove
we got the pass and we drive the thing
about the Grand Canyon you remember when
we went there was the elevation changes
imperceptible it's but your base
basically flat for all intents and
purposes driving up all the way through
the gate to the parking lot that is you
get out of the car and then you walk
through some some trees and then you're
at the rim of the Grand Canyon so it's
just like you get you you park the car
and you get out now I walked ahead and
we even took Jade because I mean you
could take a dog on the there the Rim
Trail and I'm like running ahead so that
you know I got to the edge before the
family and I turned around cuz I like
I'd already seen it but they had never
seen the Grand Canyon so I got there I
turned around in order to watch their
reaction to coming up to the edge of the
Grand Canyon and see over camera time no
man mental picture mental picture got it
because if you're filming something
you're not really experiencing mmm
technique for that yeah you could just
felt you can have it down there got a
hold it and then you got to be in the
moment right I can't be in on the screen
you got to look and film at the same
time we actually took a helicopter tour
and the
moment that we came over the the rim
that's the best a big moment in a
helicopter tour when the bottom drops
out here over the freakin Grand Canyon I
filmed that while looking out the window
hmm there's decent footage that I'll
never watch again but this is a special
moment so I turn around and like the
family's like coming up and they're
there's actually not that excited
already been in an RV all day yeah
but they hadn't seen the Grand Canyon
yet and then they get to the they get to
the edge and it was that was the moment
for me was seen like I mean even Lincoln
who like he's hard to face man he's a
middle child he's just like I'm just
here don't demand too much of me he's
kind of his outlook on life like I could
tell he was like dang it his real big
deeper that Grand that's what he said
it's deeper than I thought it would be
but I could tell that he was kind of
like blown away that was pretty cool and
then I turned and I looked at Christie
she was crying like she was like I'm I'm
crying I'm literally looking at
something in nature that has just hit me
over the head so hard that I'm crying so
that was pretty cool in it even having
seen it once for a couple hours and I
think we went to the exact same spot
that you and I went when we first saw
the over the South South Rim it's
amazing I mean it's just the pictures
just don't do it justice man you got to
see it in person so it's it's pretty
mind-blowing
and we did do a helicopter tour which it
was okay I mean it was it was awesome
what we saw but like the pilot didn't
really have anything to say he didn't
give you a play-by-play like you guys in
Kauai yeah the guy in Kauai was awesome
yeah that was awesome
and like they would time like grassy
park we had we had different we had
different oh we had different guy
different guys but my guy was incredible
and you all they play the music at the
right time
there was some music supposedly at the
right time but when we're about to go
over the rim like we've been there's
like a eight minute flight before you
get to the Grand Canyon
and the whole time Lando is upset
because his his headset microphone won't
work so when he talks he can't hear
himself and no one can hear him and so
in over the course of that like eight
minute trip like he just it just he got
more upset more upset more while you're
on the helicopter yeah Ana and so then
I'm getting upset I'm like I'm like
we're getting close this is the moment
it costs a lot of money go on a
helicopter oh yeah and I'm like this is
the moment it's what I'm thinking and
like he's about to blow his top cuz he
just he wants to talk and he's he's
concerned about something and we don't
know what it is and like he's talking to
Christy and I'm like huh and then it I'm
like we're about to go over I might I
have to salvage this so that everybody
can enjoy the moment we go over the edge
yeah so here I am being dad of the year
like snatching the headset off of
Lincoln and awful and oh and like
switching them and Lexie no you users
he's not talking anyway you just and
there's other people in the helicopter
with us oh yeah clearly due to another
couple and the pilot and I'm showing my
tail like let's just take his headset do
you take is because you're not talking
anyway said what is it you did you want
to say and then went what did Lando say
when he got ahead he said what does
terrain mean the pilot had said the word
terrain eight minutes earlier Yeah right
right
what is terrain pairing him up inside no
context really we're good the window
what the heck is terrain I told him I
know I calmed down I was like I told him
and then I and I did get to film going
over the edge and I'll never watch it
back but what you know it's interesting
because uh-huh it's really awesome I
know that Kristi was was a
a little nervous about getting on the
helicopter and even though she did it
Kauai so having done it once whose
lesson her she hates flying but she she
sent we have a little group text with
our families and a few other friends and
so she's like sinan text she's sitting a
text like alright we're about to go on
this helicopter about to do helicopter
and so then our friend Caroline was like
is it windy and she was kind of just
screwing with you a little bit but then
yeah we were like well it was windy and
they delayed it a few hours but it's
cleared up now and then you guys went on
the trip and you took a picture of
yourself and like we're all fine so
everybody knew that you were okay and
you landed it at that point Caroline
said good I'm glad because a couple of
weeks ago my friend took the helicopter
tour at the Grand Canyon and the
helicopter in front of them fell out of
the sky and crashing exploded and
everyone died and I'm reading that and
you thought it was a joke and it wasn't
it wasn't look at that and not and not
everybody died I think more than half of
the people in the helicopter died and
then some people got out but that's
crazy that that happened well I mean I'm
like I was trying to figure out is she a
good friend for not telling us or
forsake us you do I mean cuz he was
still would have done it I mean it's a
freak accident it happens
helicopters are not particularly safe
but they are relatively safe and this
one when the wind picked up it did I was
nauseous almost the whole time
yeah really yes it was like it was
waggle it wasn't gonna side angle it
wasn't going up and down it was like
waggling and that was disconcerting I
would have done well with that because I
get sick in that situation yeah but it
was awesome I mean you we went over the
widest part of the Grand Canyon and
there's a there's a it's got a ninety
degree turn in it right there there's
lots of turns in it but uh how low how
close did you go how far did you go down
uh not at this point we didn't go down
into it at another point we went down
just a little bit where you're just
below the surface of it but they don't
let go all the way down to the river
known
no now they could probably at other
places like my dad took a helicopter
ride from Vegas to the the western end
and they landed and had a meal at the at
the by the Colorado River and then took
off well you could just go to Vegas and
do it yeah and it and it doesn't cost
any more money than what I paid to just
go eight minutes from the place but it
was I mean they talked about there's
this one plateau in the middle of the
Grand Canyon this particular place
that's like sacred for the Native
Americans that settled there and they
would climb the sheer cliffs of this
plateau in the middle of this part of
the Grand Canyon and have ceremonies
there like in parties and such that was
pretty awesome that stuck with me just
just picturing that happening did you
see the glass walkway no that that
that's that's on the Indian Reservation
that's in the western end of the Grand
Canyon it's not in the the South Rim
part the North Rim was still closed
because it was snow and we flew over all
of that so it's a thousand feet higher
the North Rim versus the South Rim I
mean it was fabulous the RV life was
pretty good so you're sleeping in the RV
at night yeah it was a good bonding
experience for our family like the food
situation we ate dinner out like we'd
we'd walk from the RV place to like
dinner but like lunch and then snacks
and stuff we didn't RV and breakfast
cooking and cooking breakfast in the RV
on the stove Christy made yeah gas stove
she made her signature scrambled eggs
cheese and sausage mm-hmm that she would
send with us when we'd go camping we had
that one morning yeah it's good I mean
it's good to have like a wing that kind
of goes out and expands and gets a
little bit know my mind didn't have that
had one bed in the back and then the
couch
became a futon bed and then the the
table and two bench seats like a booth
configuration became a bed and then
there was the bed area over the
how do you I don't think I could do this
with my kids because my kids cannot keep
anything clean or straight like I was
cleaning I was straightening new
cleanings your kids like many times my
kids to continue to live in them we had
like adjoining rooms at this place and
because I can't share a room with them I
just that would kill them all
so I can't share a room I have to be in
a separate place try giving them
headsets but then I go in there and it's
like the way that they've unpacked is it
was just taking the suitcase and just
turn it over it's like the but they
haven't they say that that's what they
say they haven't done that but it's like
it's like a wild animal came in and got
in the suitcase and then busted its way
out of the suitcase and that's what was
left like that's how they unpack yeah
it's it's it's tight quarters in there
it's difficult if if I had 7 more inches
I'm talking about height okay I wouldn't
if I was as tall as you yeah Claire
father it would be difficult I mean I
took a shower in the RV and it was um it
was rather cramped yeah I water the
water was not I mean it got like in the
20s at night so the water was very cold
and the heater took the edge off of it
but it was still a cold shower well in a
tight our it's funny you mentioned the
shower and the RV because probably at
the time that you were experiencing that
I was having the exact opposite
experience in the spa at the resort oh
you know you're gonna gloat about the
spa and because this is where another
funny story occurred okay so we both
like a good massage I we've established
that I love a massage III my calling in
life is to be a massage critic like
that's that that's what I need to be
doing really I don't know there's a
market for that but I just travel around
and give people notes on the massages
they've given me that's what I want to
do in my life I got the best massage
I've ever gotten really this woman went
so aggressive I mean it was like I told
her she said how aggressive I said I
want you to go hard and then I'll tell
you to back off and I didn't tell her to
back
and I should have was it there were
points when you had to concentrate on
your breathing oh yeah I was when I was
dancing I was the faces if you could
have seen the face through the hole
there was a whole cam on the bottom of
the table we have one of the buddy says
yeah you would have been but it wasn't
the great massage then you wrote a horse
and you got a good massage I had a great
time and so then after the massage I
like to use the facilities of the spa
you know I get you get access to the spa
you get access to the steam room the
sauna the plunge pool the hot tub oh
yeah and so like take a dump I didn't
know yeah nothing I mean I may have done
that as well but that that's not what I
was referring to do that before the
massage yeah but you don't want them
pushing in a certain place and then it's
the release valve there's few things
that I enjoy more than just walking
around a spa naked you know there's just
something that in the mint it's a min
only area horse yeah and don't go into
the co-ed area naked that would I would
get a quick escort reprimand and so I I
just love the feeling of freedom and
there's just something about just being
just a human with nothing else except a
wedding ring and you know meleave and I
think it's a healthy exercise and you
just feel like you're one with nature
except you're still in a spa in a resort
yeah you're not out in the in the woods
but I don't like to have conversations
while naked with other naked men oh that
is not my idea of a good time though and
and so in and and I thought that this
was kind of the spa code you know when
we're naked let's not talk maybe I was
wrong so well if maybe if you're
submerged and there's lots of bubbles
but no no wait yeah what you're in the
hot tub you can talk but like you next
to each other at lockers other than
excuse me yeah you know or my lockers
there yeah
but especially when you're in the sauna
okay
so I love a sauna love it love a steam
room - I like going in but
but I'm in the sauna just the dry sauna
you can see everything you know there's
no steam obscuring anything in there and
so I'm just sitting in there on a towel
of course but I'm on the towel I'm not
in the towel I'm out in all my glory
well the red stirrer is on full display
okay and shout out red MC on Instagram I
don't post those kinds of pictures but
just always a good time to shout out cuz
it always is because their sensor don't
Instagram I couldn't do it I could
probably tweet naked pictures but now
I'm not that kind of guy this is just
for me so I'm sitting in there on my
towel and then a man comes in and sits
down he's also naked he doesn't sit
right next to me he sits catty-corner
you know okay 90 degrees he's like I
could tell that he had he was about to
say something
how was the massage oh how was the
massage and I'm thinking is this guy
like a man CEO of the resort is he
trying to get my opinion that's
interesting cuz that's what I wanted to
do give my opinion but not in that sand
I said it was great period period yeah
didn't did not ask good question back to
him there was he volleyed to me and I
just caught the ball you know what I'm
saying he does not volley it back it's
like you swallowed it I mean I answered
him and then the questions came were you
where you're from what you're doing here
and we're having this conversation and I
may have you ever how many bones have
you broken and so 27,000 it doesn't take
a few it takes only a few questions to
get to the point where now I've got to
talk about what I do for a little and
then then there's this weird moment in
which I'm like if I say the right
combination of answers then he's gonna
just go on the internet and look at what
I do and now he's gonna have this
picture of the man that he spoke to
naked as theirs
is on the Internet and that just makes
me feel weird
the comments could be weird so I told
him I was a high school principal I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding
I wish I had had done that because I
told him what I did good to have me I
would totally believe you coulda you
could have spun that yarn at least five
minutes I told him what I did I
mentioned the name of the show you know
he works you exposed yourself
I totally emotional self in every way I
could was completely naked and he's like
well let me write that down well I'm so
gonna have to do that I learned that he
was not just a guest he was a local he
lives there and he has access to this
particular spa just being a local this
is where he meets people yep well this
is where he talks to people okay and
friendly guy great guy great
conversation other than the fact that we
were both naked he's listening right now
potentially and shout-out to his
Instagram so that would be appropriate
yeah I didn't get I didn't get that I
don't even know his name so then two
days later you didn't ask him and he's
asking you all these questions you
didn't ask him I don't know I look I
learned what heals furtively don't know
his name and I can't remember his first
name he's just he he's from Canada he
comes down to the to this he's in
finance a few days later you're telling
me you ran in two days later I go back I
get a day pass for the spa cuz I'm like
boy I gotta get back in that sauna I
love it love the steam room so love the
conversation so now I'm sitting out I'm
sitting out next to the the plunge pool
in a robe you not make it at this point
because it's a little different when
you're out there in it right right
there he is again he comes out to the
jacuzzi gets naked
yeah gets into the jacuzzi he's five
feet from me
I'm like is he gonna talk to me now he
seen me naked I told him the name of the
show he says I watched your show
yeah and was he talking about the sauna
no talking he's like the one with the
guy from walking dead with the pudding
oh yeah he said is that what you do
every time but I was like we know we
don't eat pudding every time he's like
no do you have it like a guest I was
like what we're having it I kind of
explained but then but the whole time
I'm just thinking did you think of me
differently
mmm when you watched the show and you'd
see me naked that would have been a good
question but I didn't ask that
oh you didn't you felt weird man see you
you got oh you got to go full force
you're saying that I should have just
completely exposed myself and yeah not
worried and he was right he doesn't care
he was he doesn't can you were you this
is my problem you you are not fully
developed in your neck I got to get more
naked more often you got to get more
naked more often look he's got a heavy
conversational assignment taken you got
to do it when I was in a similar
situation I was the first person in the
hot tub area and I just had my robe on
this is before getting a massage and
pret of IATA mm-hmm and I got naked I
get in the hot tub
turn on the bubbles it's a big one
probably could have held eight to ten
men I was the only one in it and then
I'm like you know what I'm gonna express
my dominance over this place I thought
you guys express your inner glow and I
just this was before my massage I'm just
loosening up
so I instead of sitting on the bench
seats at the edge I get in the middle of
the rounds hot tub and I just proceeded
to do stretching and yoga just there
like like warrior pose right and then
guys start coming in and then I'm like
you're stretching I'm stretching I might
you know what I'm gonna be the weird
naked guy standing in the middle of the
hot tub stretching yeah that no one's
gonna join me and nobody joined me or
had a conversation with me so I
recommend that next time just that's the
way to shut it all down
yeah
next time you're naked no one to talk to
somebody just go into the warrior pose
okay like that I'll do that i-i-i-i
gotta-i we got to extend time a little
bit cuz I gotta tell you one more thing
that happen grand Kenny was awesome
our tour guide for we took another tour
which was like it was called a jeep tour
because we were in kind of a jeep but it
wasn't that kind of a Jeep tour he was
on Travelocity they said you got to get
Verner
he's a German guy hmm so I requested him
he was awesome I mean you got to read
your Travelocity reviews before you
start booking tours and stuff like that
because you probably could have heard
about your curly guy yep and you should
leave a review to that end but everyone
was recommending this guy he was awesome
teaching the kids about geology how the
Grand Canyon was made taking us to
secret spot right see an elk just wild
elk you saw elk yeah there because we
went on these dirt roads leading up to
the Grand Canyon you could stop and see
elk around there was awesome and then
we're talking to him and he's like well
are you leaving when are you leaving
where I told him well we're gonna stop
in the RV halfway getting back to LA and
he said well you should take depending
on where you're gonna stop you should
take old route 66 for a little bit and
go to the Grand Canyon caverns the Grand
Canyon caverns Grand Canyon caverns
never heard of that never heard of that
some of the largest dry caverns in North
America maybe in the world typically a
cavern is wet like you know the Linville
caverns and all that type of stuff works
like stalactites and stalagmites
dripping we decided to take him up on
his offer so first of all I'm driving on
route 66 in an RV I am daddy so hard
I just felt awesome I had cleaned out
the Dookie chute the morning before we
left and I did it right nothing spewed
anywhere it shouldn't go good I was
wearing gloves you got it I hide on a
hat and a jacket boots and all the
Dookie ran out of our RV
and the pea and the shower and same
water you were duking in there yeah yes
I I did not take your vice very early on
I found out I'm not gonna stop and go on
public toilets when I have one right
here and I had these tablet holds you
not to do this and I'm called your bluff
buddy cuz I did some research and I got
these blue tablets that you put down in
the tank before you start doing number
two down there and I couldn't there was
no stopping the kids from doing it and I
had a little stomach hooker issue so and
so I just the convenience was unmatched
and it worked you didn't smell Dookie it
worked it worked okay well I had to
empty that thing out twice on our
excursion well so much for not Dookie in
an RV it was the first thing even really
extra it really was fine you had a bad
experience in that trailer and it
doesn't it doesn't translate to my
experience but we had a bad experience
with the RV and uh going across the
country your 2008 ten years ago that's
true and in a bus that time you got to
put the tablets in I don't know how long
you can drive on route 66 I mean it's
like a two-lane road before there was a
four-lane road if you've seen cars you
understand that like this was this was
like the way man
you could take your car and go across
America from Chicago to LA mm-hmm so in
this particular part we detoured off
highway 40 in order to go to Grand
Canyon caverns and being on route 66 was
pretty fun it was pretty awesome it was
kind of desolate it's it's what what you
think it would be and Google Maps tells
me okay pull over here here's Grand
Canyon caverns and it's just no signage
no it's just a dirt road and I'm like
this is and there's a dumpster
we trashes the largely wet dry caverns
in America and this is what the interest
looks like and I was at the wrong
entrance so good but then I get back on
the road and I go another mile and I'm
like it dis looks like a gas station but
it says grand cavern Grand Canyon
caverns in and then you drive through
this thing and it looks like it's
still 1960 like old service station and
then you drive about two miles down this
like patchy paved road and you get to
just a one-story building with like four
or five cars parked in front of it and
it says in huge letters on the side of
the building Grand Canyon caverns 2018
come to find you the year I come to find
out that every year they changed the
year on the front of it because people
like to take pictures in front of it
there's like a huge dinosaur that looks
like it's from a miniature golf set
miniature golf location of course this
is like a straight out of 1960s
tourist trap right and it hasn't they
don't have enough money to like change
it that much and I'm pretty excited the
kids are looking at me like where are we
Christi's like thinking if we go in here
are we ever gonna come out right and
that's this is not the caverns this is
just peel and a half this is just the
building get in there there's some
people eating at the diner like eating
the biggest pieces of pie I've ever seen
and then there's a gift shop that has
the saddest thirty year-old knickknacks
you could ever imagine and like magnets
from there was a magnet from Topsail
Island North Carolina that you could buy
it was weird man they were like stuffed
scarecrow ish type people you know if
you took like country clothes and put
them like stuff them full of hay like a
scarecrow like put them up on chairs up
above it's hard to explain but it's just
weird I don't understand you know what
you don't want to get locked in here at
night and then you go to you go to the
far end of it and there is an elevator
and you can pay you pay your money and I
paid the money we went back into the
parking lot and ate our lunch and then
we they gave us poker chips and with
these poker chips were able to get in
the elevator with a tour guide and go
down 200 feet 2,000 feet go down 2,000
feet into
these caverns what and we start hearing
the story of 1927
a guy was riding his horse and it was
pouring down rain and he stops on the
way to where he was going to like under
a tree and he realizes that all the rain
water's running in this hole and it's
not filling up and he comes back the
next day with his with his brother he's
a little brother I think and he ties a
rope around him and lowers him always
lower the brother not younger the
younger brother with a lantern down into
this cavern the guy thinks that he finds
gold there's like all types of shiny
ores down there and he thinks he's hit
the jackpot and they buy like all this
land up while they're like getting
samples of what it is they've got which
turns out to be nothing except a big
hole actually a pretty huge hole sounds
like it so he starts charging like 25
cents to lower people on a rope down
into this thing in order to just explore
these caverns which we were now walking
around in and it's like there's no
stalactites and stalagmites I mean
millions of years ago like the limestone
deposits were eaten away as water
started to run through this thing and it
formed these huge caverns which fresh
air comes in from the Grand Canyon from
the bottom yeah and then comes up to the
top yeah
there's no water flowing through this
thing now it's sealed off so it's dry
and nothing can live in there and they
found like a bobcat that died in the
they did some carbon dating on it and it
was they kept it down in there and they
said this Bobcat died in like the
mid-1800s and it still was like
preserved like a piece of taxidermy
because there's there's nothing
happening down there there's a hotel
room down there no there's a well it's
just a there's a section where they
built a deck in this big open room and
there's a bed and a television and
they're rented out of the room
to this day yeah
I love this I knew you would love
underground stuff I knew you would love
it and then they'll do like spelunking
look Jacob as a picture there that's
that's like the huge main room there's
all these different rooms I mean it's
all kind of touristy and janky like they
build a bar down there and you can pay
like yeah and there and the whole time
the good old days when you could just
find a hole in the ground and build a
build a bar down there without somebody
coming along and saying you can't do
that oh and they'll also give you
spelunking gear and send you down into
like these little holes where you can
like like shimmy around in your belly
and go into other rooms like if you can
make it and Noah there was this one
family doing that and tell me how many
other mothers the mom was too scared
they were like five other people in our
45 minute tour and there were maybe
eight cars in the parking lot how much
did the court were closed for five of us
I think it'd end up being 90 bucks well
that's good
there was a mom who was had the
spelunking gear on but she wasn't in
there I was like you know you you did
you come out of that hole she was like I
chickened out I didn't want to go down
in that and then she looked at me again
and she was like are you on the Internet
she's like you have to wait here until
my daughter comes out of this hole but
you weren't naked at the time no I I
wouldn't know I was fully clothed I took
the tour clothes
good bye good idea I'm just bragging a
little bit that I was recognized yeah
thanks to my internet celebrity yeah
from a mom of a girl who I had to wait
to come out of well I'm out of the hole
in order to take a picture with me in
this dry cavern we get to this one place
and they have a replica a hairy replica
of a giant prehistoric sloth this place
is amazing because they found the
complete skeleton of a sloth down in
there and they sent it to a museum and
in exchange for giving them the skeleton
the museum sent them a hairy replica of
the sloth which they put in the cavern
and
that's better than the bones and you can
see where it it was actually a baby
giant sloth oh but it was still probably
I mean 15 feet tall what and it was you
can they said if you look up there you
can see where it scratched the walls
trying to get out trying to get out very
slowly and then it died yeah slowly
scratching the walls and they know that
because they found the the claw which
they have on display in a case up up
above along with this is like the
coolest place in America a Native
American flautist who did a did an audio
recording down there so there's like
pictures of that guy get that CD no I
took a picture of it good been blessing
I think is the guy's name been blessing
a picture of it because I was like we
gotta put that character in a movie and
then I started to think this whole thing
is a movie whole thing uh what are they
what I'm unabashedly pitching to you I
want to take you there right I don't
want you to believe me yet but we need
to turn this cavern into a movie and
it's gonna be set in two different times
I'm dead serious about this okay
it's gonna cut back and forth between
the discovery the discovery of the cave
and that the present-day when this this
washed-up tourist trap off route 66 is
they do weddings down there too but and
then there's like theater seating that
they took out of the American Film
Institute theater in Hollywood and the
tour guide is like and all these
celebrities have sat in these theater
seats right here and you can buy two of
them for $1,500 what they're selling
them they're selling everything I don't
think it's just a new period I think
it's trying to make money
I think it's throughout the ages no I
think it cuts back a fourth book I think
it missed the 60 I think this story is
about now how it's a relative inherited
this place and it has got to make it
work
in present day but it keeps cutting back
to his ancestors that discover the place
I think there's a movie in there I'll be
the guy lower down in the rope and we
show the movie yes we is a one theatre
release and that we only show the movie
in the hole well that's you have to go
to the hole to see the movie about the
hole which you can watch the whole movie
that's what we call it the whole movie I
feel like you're selling my idea a
little short oh I think it's great I'm
selling it deep man I'm selling it mm I
seat down because I know I think this is
a I think it's a I think it's I mean it
has comedic elements but I don't think
it's it's like tonally I think this
movie is like I don't know what but it's
like that Bernie movie with Jack Black
that we saw that's like yes it's so
strange like everything is so strange
such a war it's a world that I think we
can just I like the idea I think that
it's like that movie we saw at Sundance
that wiener dog and I hated wiener dog
by the way the movie yeah it was
horrible but it followed the wiener dog
from owner to owner and I did I just
didn't like the way it was done I know
some people like that filmmaker is just
I can't get into it but I just wonder if
there's a way to tell I've seen a movie
like this that were they actually told a
convincing like a gripping convincing
story around a location you're talking
about a dog's purpose no well I I need
to take you there to excuse him you know
what it is um oh gosh you tell about the
giving tree no no no which we should
adapt into a movie again this is not
this is better than wiener dog
I think it's called ghost story it's got
a is it Casey Affleck see the one the
controversial actor and and then I think
the the the the woman in it is the Olsen
twins sister I can't remember anyway but
it's a
it's about a location it's about a house
and everybody who goes through in it but
it starts but it starts back in the like
the the way way way way back like not
hunter-gatherer but like frontier and
but this guy is he's a ghost and he's
there the whole time and he like it's
where there is a ghost down there and
see there's you can have there's a ghost
tour that they do at night and you can
spend the night in there well originally
when he would lower somebody in on a
rope after charging $0.25 he would come
back and get him later unless he forgot
which he would frequently do you'd be
down there with a lantern he didn't he
just wasn't he wouldn't drop the rope
until the next day hold on hold on I'm
talking now about how deep 1927 2,000
feet you hold on to a rope and he brings
you up 2,000 feet yeah originally the
very first tourists I'm fly I'm flashing
back he has lights down there no he
would he would you would go down with a
lamp lantern and matches I doesn't want
to go I think there could be a movie
about it it's so kitschy you know is
that like that whole this tourist trap
type thing but it's legitimately a
geological feet I mean it's like but
it's it's it's suffering it's not doing
that great you know I don't know I love
that night man because well I want to go
right now I think if we made the movie
it really really turned the place around
maybe we buy it turn that whole upside
down to a pillar and it doesn't really
work that way
No
the kids Lando loved it the the other
kids were they they were okay with it
okay with it yeah hmm maybe we could
it's the movie that will change to make
some updates to it right I got a couple
ideas laser show one of them laser show
down there any I've never you can tell
me one location on earth where a laser
show didn't make it more exciting then
I'll buy you a laser show okay I'll take
you up on that offer into Stone Mountain
Georgia laser show laser show
yeah Red Rocks laser show Grand Canyon
caverns not yet yeah they need one lady
show be DLS alright guys I I took a risk
and telling you about my movie idea
don't don't steal it just believe in I
don't go make that movie we will we will
come after you with everything we've got
right like the two Horsemen of the
Apocalypse I'll be on a white horse and
Lincoln being an RV he's not really a
horse it's gonna take him a lot of get
going it's gotta back out of his
driveway but once he gets going buddy
he's got all kinds of momentum lots of
legal authority you gotta watch out will
speak at you next week thanks for thanks
for hanging out with us as we tell each
other about our vacations
[Music]